اندلعت مواجهه بين فلسطينيين وقوات
الاحتلال ببلده العيساويه بالقدس المحتله
اليوم وبثت وسائل اعلام فلسطينيه مشاهد
تظهر جانبا من المواجهات ولحظه اشتعال
حافله حاله انها لمستوطنين وافادت وسائل
الاعلام بان قوات الاحتلال ادعت ان
الحافله دخلت بلده العيساويه بالخطا وهذه
هي الصور من هناك قبل قليل
[موسيقى]
اذا حول هذه الاوضاع تنضم الينا من رام
الله مراسله الجزيره جيفارا البديري
جيفارا ماذا تعرفين عن مواجهات بلده
العيساويه وما الذي يجري هناك
في ذات السياق الان يتم الحديث عن حدث
امني حسب وصف الاحتلال الاسرائيلي فيما
يعرف بشارع 60 بالقرب من بلده السعير في
محافظه الخليل وهناك على ما يبدو اطلاق
النار على جيب عسكري على الشارع الالتفافي
المحاذي لبلده سعير جنوب الخليل ولكننا لا
زلنا بانتظار رد رسمي وبيان من الناطق
بلسان قوات الاحتلال هذا الناطق وايضا
قوات الاحتلال التي كانت قد زعمت قبل
حوالي اربع ساعات من الان بان الشابه
فلسطينيه حسب مزاعم البيان على الفور سارع
الى الحديث ان شابه فلسطينيه قامت
باستخدام مسدس واطلاق النار على جنود
اسرائيليين بالقرب من مسافر يطا جنوب
الخليل اقصى جنوب الضفه الغربيه وانه تم
اطلاق النار عليها على الفور ليتضح بعد
ذلك
ان من كانت هذه الشابه هي ليست شابه
فلسطينيه بل مستوطنه اسرائيليات تعاني من
امراض نفسيه وعقليه
وقامت بارتداء ملابس اسلاميه كشابه
فلسطينيه في محاوله للانتحار وبالتالي
واضح ان الجيش الاسرائيلي هو الان في حاله
ارتباك يمكن ان يطلق النار كما حدث في
السابق على اي فلسطيني بزعم باي مزاعم قد
تكون موجوده شكرا لك يا جيفارا البديري
مراسله الجزيره من رام الله
وبالطبع سوف نعود لك في حال ورود اي
تطورات اخرى